[Musica]
1880 la lampadina elettrica a filo
incandescente 1928 il motore dell'harley
davidson 1973 la tuta delle missioni
apollo quelle che hanno portato l'uomo
sulla luna 1986 il primo computer ad uso
domestico 2018 la tastiera touchscreen
alcune delle invenzioni brevettate che
più hanno avuto successo nella storia e
ognuna di queste invenzioni ha
naturalmente il suo inventore thomas
edison william harley steve jobs non
tutti sono anche proprietari dei loro
brevetti
pensiamo ad apple ma dalla qualifica di
inventore derivano diritti patrimoniali
e morali capite quindi che la parola
invenzione è sinonimo di futuro di
progresso di creatività ma è una parola
che ha una specifica rilevanza anche
nella sfera del diritto
ecco perché vi parlo di invenzioni anche
se io l'innovazione non la genero
suggerisco come tutelare le invenzioni
come sfruttarli economicamente
talvolta le difendo nelle aule dei
tribunali quando altri se ne appropriano
indebitamente checov è un'invenzione
secondo il diritto
la soluzione tecnica di un problema
tecnico deve essere nuova è dotata di
altezza inventiva non deve cioè essere
ovvia e banale
per l'esperto di settore colui che
conosce tutto dello stato della tecnica
se a queste caratteristiche
un'invenzione può essere brevettata i
documenti che avete visto poco fa che
conferiscono all'inventore un diritto
esclusivo di sfruttare quell'invenzione
per un massimo di 20 anni ma ad un patto
che gli descriva quell'invenzione
in maniera tanto dettagliata da
permettere a chiunque di replicarla allo
scadere del brevetto e nel frattempo
tutti possono studiarla per superarla
per andare oltre verso il progresso
della società
ecco il patto tra stato inventore un
diritto esclusivo a fronte della
divulgazione dell'invenzione
quanti di voi sanno che tutti i brevetti
della storia sono liberamente
accessibili a chiunque un sapere lì
pronto per essere studiato e superato
ecco chi è allora l'inventore con lui
che crea un ponte tra ciò che esiste può
essere studiato e ciò che ancora deve
essere inventato
eccovi che thomas edison ci ha
traghettato dall illuminazione a gas
all'illuminazione elettrica che steve
jobs ha eliminato la tastiera dai nostri
cellulari ma oggi l'uomo l'inventore non
è più l'unico che ha accesso a quel
patrimonio di conoscenze oggi a un
concorrente l'intelligenza artificiale
una tecnologia che tra le altre è capaci
di apprendere da un set di dati e di
conoscenze e a partire da quel set di
dati e conoscenze crea immagini testi
video perfino soluzioni tecniche ma chi
è allora inventore nell'attuale sistema
tecnologico nemmeno chi programma
l'intelligenza artificiale è in grado di
prevedere fino in fondo quale il
risultato riporterà questa macchina
creativa i pensatori del nostro tempo ci
mettono in guardia rispetto a questa
situazione in cui l'uomo perde la
capacità di anticipare gli effetti del
suo agire si perde il senso della storia
il passato si traduce nel superato e il
futuro semplicemente nel perfezionamento
di un risultato secondo un equilibrio
economico tra le risorse a disposizione
e gli obiettivi da raggiungere ma come
si pone il giurista in questo contesto
quelle che vedete alle mie spalle sono
due invenzioni un contenitore con il
bordeaux frastagliato e una lampada a
led lampeggiante per segnalare le
emergenze
entrambe queste invenzioni sono state
oggetto di un brevetto e sapete chi è
indicato quale inventore davus un
intelligenza artificiale ma l'ufficio
statunitense è anche quello italiano
hanno rifiutato di riconoscere la
qualifica di inventore a un intelligenza
artificiale sul presupposto che il
nostro attuale sistema legislativo
qualifica come inventore soltanto una
persona fisica e per la verità
l'ufficio statunitense già si era
occupato di questa questione
rifiutando di riconoscere i diritti
d'autore a naruto un macaco che si era
fatto un self utilizzato poi da alcune
riviste di settore
ma si sa il diritto arriva sempre in
ritardo rispetto alla realtà e basta una
semplice maggioranza per cambiare le
cose nel 2017 in arabia saudita
sophie è stata riconosciuta cittadina è
quindi necessario trovare una
giustificazione più convincente per non
riconoscere come inventore un
intelligenza artificiale e forse la
definizione di invenzione secondo il
diritto può essere d'aiuto
la soluzione tecnica ad un problema
tecnico e attenzione il diritto
riconosce invenzione anche se inventore
non ha fatto alcuno sforzo anche se
l'invenzione è stata frutto del caso di
un colpo di fortuna pur che l'uomo sia
in grado di cogliere la portata non
banale di quella soluzione
nell'ottica di risolvere il problema
tecnico
le invenzioni create con l'ausilio
dell'intelligenza artificiale
effettivamente sono proprio questo una
soluzione trovata per caso per un colpo
di fortuna ma è ancora l'inventore che
si pone il problema tecnico che sceglie
che cosa far studiare a questa in questa
intelligenza artificiale che seleziona
tra i risultati
stati proposti quello che meglio risolve
il suo problema è l'inventore che si
pone il problema è la risoluzione di
quel problema è il suo scopo
finché la macchina non farà questo passo
ulteriore
il processo inventivo è ancora sotto la
responsabilità dell'uomo è giusto quindi
che il diritto valorizzi questa capacità
dell'inventore di porsi un problema
tecnico di cogliere la portata non
banale di una soluzione trovata
magari per caso in questa prospettiva il
progresso resta appannaggio dell'uomo e
la tecnologia è uno strumento al suo
servizio
proprio come lo era il fuoco di prometeo
non a caso però matthus colui che
riflette prima colui che vede in
anticipo credo sia allora proprio questa
capacità dell'uomo di porsi uno scopo di
porsi un problema a distinguerlo dalla
macchina e ciò che rende l'inventore un
ponte verso il futuro
[Applauso]
[Musica]